make it sound like you're more poly and
willing to date other people your
lifestyle choices are extremely abnormal
and not at all like most poly people I
mean do you really just see me as a
friend still how is that even possible
to be that callous and cold Destiny I
don't want to believe that you
are really quick really quick a little
context cuz I don't know if he he
includes this uh she Destiny tells her
that he's polyamorous now she replies uh
or in her mind she's like oh paully
amoris he uh Anna thinks Destiny is
paully is in he will have multiple
serious Partners Destiny is paully in
reality that he has one serious partner
being Molina and then multiple women
that he's just allowed to sleep with so
she's under the impression that they're
like about to have a serious
relationship right that's how she's
going into it so that's that's kind of
[Music]
okay listen if you're not going to take
me at my word we can just read the
report and we can find out that way okay
no no I I'm willing to listen to your
word but um oh you'll listen to it
you'll listen to it via this all right
okay sure sure sure sure Stephen Kenneth
bonell II also known as Destiny is a
34-year-old political streamer and was
an early Pioneer of professional live
streaming as it exists
today thoughts wow uh you proed me some
music on huh oh yeah is that good is
that good is that quiet that's nice
music might put it on a little low yeah
I could tell by the Japanese depiction
of a white woman that's scantily clad
yeah she's 17 giveway oh my
goodness I don't really care maybe maybe
she is mature
enough okay okay okay
he aims to stream 10 hours per day 7
days a week thousands of viewers
congregate for the duration of every
stream his YouTube channel currently
sits at
6,41 or 641 th000 subscribers and
averages over 10 million views per month
he's not public about his income but
I'll disclose that I earned around 3,500
a month on YouTube with close to 4,000
subscribers and a fraction of Destiny's
engagement level so he's he's making
million of dollars a year wow that
that's I know about YouTube ad Revenue I
know about you know roughly what ads he
gets he gets in the same amount of money
all right that's good okay well it's not
good he's a rapist he's a rapist all
right winus well everyone's got to own
the bakaro okay even even all right
never mind no I'm not I'm not doing this
keep going keep going as with other
streamers Destiny's additional revenue
streams include merchandise sponsorship
deals and donations usually in the form
of a chat donation on his personal
website or super Chats on YouTube
audience members can pay to have Destiny
react to their chat messages in real
time more they pay the more likely he is
to react because of the semi
accessibility of creators and their
sheer volume of content live streaming
is an addictive medium but plainly
Destiny's most dedicated fans watch him
for several hours a day and give him
hundreds of dollars per month each
you're a destiny fan uh I used to I used
to pop in occasionally but no I I uh I
do not give him any money nor do I want
to according to a 2019 demographic
survey of 1,400 Destiny fans conducted
by a Community member 6% or 14 to 17 and
75% are 25 and under 93% are male 73%
are white
93% are male dude he must have that
entire 7% in his herum when he did an
IRL Meetup uh it was an issue because
there were so little women all of the
guys tried to sleep with all of the like
the the little women that were there and
they were all like harassing the women
dude that's sad oh man Destiny's
audience trusts him to okay listen you
want to talk about Anna don't you let's
hear it you want to talk about Anna I do
I guess I do all right Anna okay tell me
Destiny had sex with a small streamer
who became attached to him when she
criticized his lifestyle he called her
an insane stalker which only provoked
her to criticize him further at the same
time the destiny convinced his fans and
orbiters that of Anna's abuse claims
should be ignored for her own good he
was texting her at one point Destiny
threatened to leak Anna's nudes if she
leaked his sex he also directed his fans
to participate in harassing and doxing
Anna in retaliation for her abuse claims
oh so to to repeat that in a way that's
more human be evidence for this oh
there's plenty to to repeat this in a
more human way winus Destiny slept with
Anna then saying like oh Anna's insane
whatever then when he was off stream he
would continue to sex her then yeah that
is and when Anna was on stream saying
Destiny actually likes me I he's not I
don't know why he's calling me a stalker
me he he we're we're like sexually
active like behind the scenes when he
heard that he was like yeah if she leaks
anything that proves that I'm going to
leaker nudes that's disgusting and he
yeah he allowed his fan base to harass
her that's not anival an equivalent you
can't you shouldn't do that um I do not
I don't like that I think Destiny leads
weird relationships I think he likes
weird relationship dynamics of emotions
and push pole and arguments I I my guess
is his Tendencies towards these very
disorderly relationships is what has led
him down this path his debauchery so to
say go ahead and uh read read starting
from here okay they soon did a second
stream about altruism in which Anna
argued that doing things for people
increases psychological well-being in
quotations my opinion uh in my opinion
because she wanted to challenge
Destiny's lack of empathy that's fair
that summer Destiny proposed that he
visit Anna for a week an agreed but she
expressed concern that he would grow
distant or even cut her off after they
had sex Destiny assured her I understand
your concern but that would be a huge
time investment just to hook up with
someone XD a week before the scheduled
meeting also usage of XD if you're a
rapist it's like insane um a week before
the scheduled meeting Anna and Destiny
did a third stream a debate about
whether dark Triad antisocial
personality traits are correlated with
open relationships I wouldn't be
surprised if they are I don't know what
the conclusion to that stream is I'm
kind of curious actually for the first
90 minutes Anna try to convince destiny
that people in open relationships have
trust trust issues and avoid attachment
patterns not taking the bait Destiny
kept the conversation intellectual Anna
commented that his judgment might be
impaired because the topic hits close to
home ooh Destiny called this a power
play and they argued about it for 2
hours eventually Anna started crying and
told him he was being abusive oh was it
really abusive I I haven't seen it but
uh at this point I would say maybe not I
think cuz Anna Anna does have severe OCD
from my understanding I could be wrong
um so like at the beginning it's like a
little like okay like it's it's not a
surprise why people thought that she was
being
insane uh with with how she was acting
but towards the end of this you kind of
like giving Destiny extremely bad faith
it's almost like he saw this and
capitalized on her instability and
worked with it to try to form a
narrative that would that most people
would look at and be like yeah she's
crazy like giving him extreme bad faith
scheme that much do you think he would
scheme that much I think Destiny is yes
I think so I think so really yep I don't
think he's an idiot I think he I think
he knew what he was doing here I don't
know if it was as severe as I just
explained but listen I if you if I were
to find evidence of that and read it I
would not like be
shocked you know what that's like that's
like a NASA scientist making sfm porn
that's like such a stupid thing to waste
your time on oh my goodness especially
if you ski let's say it's a Nas a
scientist who's making sfm porn but
they're also addicted to porn and
jerking off then would it be that
surprising oh yeah no well I'm not
saying that I don't think it's possible
I'm saying that if it is possible
it's like someone who has the skills to
be a NASA scientist spending all of
their intellectual ability on making sfm
pornography um which seems to be
Destiny's case here because if you well
it could be and this is just speculation
as you said before because if this guy
has actually um well if he actually
schemed and did this whole stick for
Anna then he would be wasting his
talents anyway at the end of the 4 and a
half hour conversation Anna said that
Destiny should ban any Chatters who call
her abusive and manipulative and he
politely avoided the suggestion actually
don't think that's a big deal especially
if he if she's accusing him of being
abusive because often an abuse thing is
like the the beginning part of the Anna
stuff isn't like like I could see myself
doing the same thing I could be like I'm
not going to ban people for calling like
that's you know I probably wouldn't to
the say like if you told me to ban
people who were calling you like a
pedophile or something like I probably
wouldn't you know yeah no that's true in
mid August the week of Molina's 22nd
birthday Destiny and holy crap she's 22
Molina she was
22 uh the Molina is Destiny's at the
time wife no I know but she was 22 she's
really young I did not know she was that
12 year age Gap I believe no not 12 it
was a lot go ahead I don't like looking
at sex pet stuff like the this type of
person not this type of person this
facet of this type of person is
something I'm not particularly fond of
and kind of grosses me out in mid August
the week of molo's 22nd birthday Destiny
and Anna spent several days in a hotel
together they had sex talked and he did
his normal streams from the hotel room
despite an agreement to keep the visit a
secret in a briefly streamed from the
hotel room as well effectively outting
their sexual relation ship she would
claim this was unintentional but I'm
skeptical Anna has described Destiny as
having a Revenge kick where he
manipulate where manipulative Dynamics
involving lying and blackmail are
fetishized and I mention it now because
the rest of the story will make a lot
more sense if you are aware of this
that's true by the way okay so there you
go that's that's maybe this manipulation
of the event is actually somewhat based
in reality well while he was doing the
whole shtick where he was like yeah
she's insane and then behind the scenes
he was texting her one of the things he
sends her is he says and I I don't know
if the screenshot is going to be here I
can try to find it uh eventually but he
says I don't know I just want to lay on
your bed and rub you feet rub your feet
while you blackmail me on
Twitter like that is that is a almost
like quote that is yeah uh yes Kay if
you put in topic suggestions in the
Discord go ahead go ahead to be fair I
mean it does seem like she's kind of
participating a little bit in this right
now um I you know I mean as of right now
this is just consensual sex it doesn't
get like evil yeah yeah so and also I
will say I know that's that seems like
the stuff Destiny's into it's weird
again creating these messy situations
it's just kind of gross like I don't
know be good with your life live your
life well not like this anyway um so the
Revenge Kake at the end of the week
Destiny left to join Molina in Sweden
from the airport he DMD Anna okay about
that to board okay about to board my
first flight thanks for the past few
days and I had a lot of fun smiley face
she replied I did too Destiny heart have
safe flights talk to you later but the
next day she wrote oh boy I'm pretty sad
it just kind of hit me today out of
nowhere I also feel so angry with you
because it make it sound like you're
more Polly and willing to date other
people your lifestyle choices are
extremely abnormal and not at all like
most poly people I mean do you really
just see me as a friend still how is
that even possible to be that callous
and cold Destiny I don't want to believe
that you
are really quick really quick a little
context cuz I don't know if he he
includes this uh she Destiny tells her
that he's polyamorous now she replies uh
or in her mind she's like oh polyamorous
he uh Anna thinks Destiny is Paulie is
in he will have multiple serious
Partners Destiny is pully in reality
that he has one serious partner being
Molina and then multiple women that he's
just allowed to sleep with so she's
under the impression that they're like
about to have a serious relationship
right that's how she's going into it so
that's that's kind of context for that
message okay and we there's no way for
us to really know if he made his
intentions clear to be fair uh we we
don't really know we don't know if she's
going back something that he's already
said it's very difficult to excuse me
fully ascertain the context around this
so he replied h i mean as a friend I
mean what do you mean I mean sex stuff
aside having met you in real life and
talk to you and gone around and stuff
you're definitely a way closer friend
than you were before for sure Destiny
says in I responded with several
messages containing increasingly sharp
criticisms culminating in the fact that
you feel so entitled to get sex from
tons of different people but not have to
meet them meet their emotional needs
which are sexual needs is textbook
narcissism it's extreme entitlement and
selfishness that enables a person to
treat other human beings the way you do
it's morally reprehensible over the next
few days and I sent dozens of anxious
and critical messages with little
response from Destiny eventually he
would warn be warm again even
flirtatious but not
consistently is uh you know the push and
pull method yeah do you get that same
that same
Vibe yes I do it's okay this is this is
you know game is game this is how you do
it game is game I'm kidding game is game
is game because um meanwhile Destiny's
fans were putting the pieces together
from Anna's stream chats they asked if
should sleep with Destiny during his
trip she giggled and said they shouldn't
ask her that which many took as
confirmation not receiving the promised
detention from Destiny and I sent him
psychology to articles about
stonewalling and narcissism she also
criticized what she perceived as a
sociopathic vindictiveness in part
because of a story had told her and
others about how he once lived to his
ex's boss to get her fired from her job
one of her own stream she criticized
Destiny for moving across the country
from his son Bas when I spoke to her she
told me she' innocently mentioned some
psych psychology research about how Sons
should spend more time with their
fathers but the clip was not how she
described it at all in reality while
reading a chat message saying Destiny
was a good father Anna burst into
mocking laughter before saying yeah
because we all know to be a good father
the best thing to do is move a million
miles away from your son I'm going to
stop before he clips that someone did
and on October 5th 2020 Destiny did his
first Ana attack stream oh this is this
is going to get him like riled up too
you know he's like I find this hot you
know that Destiny s listen I'm I'm
biased because I something about like
women who are mentally ill like being
taken advantage of like really I don't
know what it is but it strikes a cord
with me so I I look at this no I I'm
being serious I'm being Ser like this
this makes me irrationally angry what he
did to Anna so I'm biased okay I'm
biased this like this is genuinely
disgusting to me this should have been
the end of Destiny's career I think yeah
this is I don't I I wouldn't say that
just yet I think this is like weirdo
behavior that I already kind of expected
from him um I don't know I I just think
this way of acting like this is kind of
gross um and not conducive to happiness
so in quotations here I have had some
clips linked to me today I don't
normally touch Bridges unless other
people want to do it first in which case
eff it he played the clip of Anna
calling him a bad father and wants into
a play byplay of their relationship
mostly complaining that she messaged him
relentlessly after they had sex one
chatter asked Destiny why are you doing
this what do you gain out of publicly
ridiculing this girl Destiny replied I'm
not trying to the problem is she just
keeps saying really effing rude and
disgusting crap about me on her stream
it's really effing irritating
she doesn't realize how effed in the
head it is one thing I will say um just
as a a quick aside I've never seen
Destiny properly address the criticism
of him moving away away from his kid has
he ever like actually addressed that uh
I wouldn't know I couldn't tell you I
don't think so I'm not going to lie dude
I think that's weird um I've seen him
like be like oh let me guess the critic
is going to say next that I moved away
from my kid it's like okay just cuz you
predict a point it doesn't mean it's a
bad point right like yeah sure a lot of
people say it but maybe there's some
validity to it I've never seen him give
a defense for it before uh so I don't
know maybe you should stay with your kid
and give them a good father figure um oh
his kids part of dgg I mean I don't
think he's going to get a good good
father figure um Nathan y that's
unfortunate dude best thing to do when
you have a kid is um if you want to see
how I'm going to say the word influ
incer I have to like do a trigger
warning before I say the word influencer
if you want to see how an influencer
should deal with having children I think
the greatest and this is commonly cited
this isn't something novel that I'm
saying here but the way that PewDiePie
has treated his um relationship in
accordance with the internet I think is
really really healthy um the way he's
been interacting with his kid his wife
he's setting a wonderful example for his
viewers be like PewDiePie don't be like
Destiny in your your relationships you
should strive for having a beautiful
family that you protect and not one that
you move away from and then have weird
immature exchanges like this where
you're messing with random girls
emotions that are like a decade old a
decade excuse me younger than you so I
don't know I think that's weird yep yep
what else let's go through let's go
through a little bit more so sure uh
Destiny repeated his complaints about
Anna's Relentless critical messages
about his psychology and then they
argued whether Anna has the right to
publicly call Destiny sexual
relationships abusive with Destiny
saying you're not allowed to express
concern with any of my personal
relationships that I don't want your
opinion on Destiny also defended his
tendency to retaliate against others
when you say you've left a trail of
Destruction behind you the implication
there is generally that I'm traumatizing
or abusing or hurting people that
otherwise don't deserve it obviously
ironic uh you know what we know now
andna replies nobody deserves that how
could you say that Destiny replies
because sometimes people do real dickish
things and I think if you do dickish
things back it's not the worst thing in
the world an a replies that doesn't give
you the right to do anything back to
them that gives you the right to
retaliate Destiny says yeah we're not
talking about who's right first of all I
have the right to do anything I want
okay [__] that Anna says no you don't
see right there entitlement Destiny says
that's not entitlement wait what do you
mean as long as I'm not hurting anybody
else I have the right to talk about or
do anything I want Anna says okay well
you just said you have the right to do
whatever you want Destiny says wait what
do you think I meant with that Anna do
you think I meant I should be able to
shoot somebody or punch somebody or
choke somebody do you really think
that's what I meant with that is that
the read we're going with here because
Anna felt obligated to keep Destiny
secret about getting his ex fired from
her job his fans were clueless about the
context of this argument M of Destiny's
Community called lonus offered a
lukewarm defense for Destiny's
vindictiveness lonus says wait Anna are
there varying degrees of abuse like is
there a greater and lesser form of abuse
Anna says lonus you cannot you seem like
a really nice person you cannot
seriously oh my God lonus says I haven't
said anything I'm just asking you Anna
says Sur yes lonus says so it could be
that maybe when Destiny is retaliating
it is a little bit abusive right it's a
little bit abusive but is it it's still
abusive lus says yes it's still abusive
but maybe in the context of Destiny
being a streamer and Destiny being an
Entertainer and these things be public
conflicts and Destiny's desire to drum
up attention there are things that a
normal person doesn't interact with
right you can't prescribe these things
that you would talk about in a normal
intimate relationship to someone who has
a wide Public Image uh and then Anna
when Anna asked Destiny if he thinks
he's harming people he replied yeah
probably if they're inflicting harm on
on to me I don't really care that much
Anna says that's what concerns me
Destiny says oh my God Ela says I think
that most people are okay with
inflicting some amount of harm on others
Anna says uh what which I think is true
to some extent I think most people come
to the like yeah you're probably okay
with inflicting some harm to be
honest uh I mean yeah depends on yeah to
some yeah to some extent yeah so this
conversation goes on for a little bit
Yeah goes on for a long bit it seems yep
BR have you ever used a nutcracker uh
like the Christmas
ones no like the metal thing you use to
break nuts open um no so you get like a
a bow I'm going to recommend this all
men in this stream right now every
single man listening and women too maybe
um listen what I want you to do right
now is go look up a bag of nuts with the
shells on and buy a
nutcracker if cracking nuts open is one
of the most gratifying masculine
experiences you know how you know how
like um what's it gender Euphoria you
know how trans people use the word
gender Euphoria for when they feel like
gratified in their position listen
that's what using a nutcracker is when
you're a man you if you work for
breaking a nut open and eating it it
first of all it tastes better when you
get it from the
shell um and oh wait I have opened two
but they are missing I have so many
hazelnuts hazelnuts are really difficult
to open and by the way you can't apply
too much pressure you have to crack the
nut with like a plier type thing or like
a little drive before you open it so it
doesn't burst otherwise if you apply too
much pressure you could hurt you or
someone around you um but I would highly
recommend nut cracking every male when
CH please look into that ASAP you'll
enjoy it and you can thank me later okay
anyway we have the first bit here all
right this is where it gets good all
right this is where it gets spicy get
nuts this is where it gets nuts that is
yeah yeah all right I like cupcakes says
Lynn yeah you're also a pedophile so you
know is that true no
that's awesome just calling random
people pedophiles when it's for no
reason
I listen it's my fan base [__] all
right I can do what I want yeah okay
yeah you can do whatever you want if you
own these people it's like straight up
like anti antibellum type you know
activity going on here yeah so this is
what Destiny's saying okay I have lived
a long and long enough and experienced
enough to know this to be true you can
refer back to this message in 5 years if
you're wondering what's going wrong you
have some insanely antisocial tendencies
that inhibit you from being able to
communicate with or understand human
beings you do not understand how people
think and feel and consequently say
unimaginably clueless or horrible things
to them good luck with everything you'll
need a ton of it if you're going to make
changes necessary to even be a somewhat
competent Communicator let alone a
therapist you would go on to block her
wow
okay he then posted screenshots of the
DMS in his public chat calling her
insane Molina replied and we all just
try to get her fired she'll kill people
with her words I hate her with all my
heart aren't these people gross Molina's
his wife to clarify no I know I know I
know who Molina is okay um I started
making dolphin sounds the moment I heard
the name so you know a fan reposted the
DMS in Destiny subreddit with the title
this is disgusting the post received
1,400 up votes in the top comment with
559 upvotes reads it's extremely common
for abusers to attempt to Discount and
minimize their victims past abuse Anna
is an abuser she is abusive an is an
abuser okay that was the narrative going
around so because of Destiny I still
really don't I feel like there's so much
context missing but I don't listen
there's a lot of conversation okay I did
Skip through a bunch of it I want to hit
the story beats okay cuz I want you to I
want you to learn about those due
diligence sure on
February 12th 2023 Destiny wrote The
Following comment on his subreddit in a
thread about alleged choking just as an
FYI I've never choked anyone to near
point of unconsciousness in my life I've
never even really choked someone it was
more just holding on to them from behind
to get them to stop hitting me blocked
on Discord and a message destiny
con consistently on Instagram for a
month with sporadic replies from Destiny
such as emoji face I think we trigger
each other far too much Anna LOL and
Anna no contact please the DMS kept
coming on March 16th Destiny apologized
to her for attacking her publicly but 6
days later on stream he said the apology
had been insincere so he apologized to
her in private unprompted randomly then
on stream he said publicly yeah I didn't
mean that what that's weird
eventually he blocked Anna on Instagram
she tried dming him on Twitter at one
point asking seriously do you wish I was
dead would you mean my Suicide for
content by the summer Destiny was
texting her again in June Anna asked
Destiny to help prepare her reputation
Destiny said if I said anything now
people would just be really dramatic and
dumb about stuff Anna replied aren't you
more concerned with Molina finding out
not so much what your fan base thinks
but also it's not like I'm some crazy
person lamu you could just say you
exaggerated Destiny says I'll cross that
bridge when it comes to it okay and
maybe in the future yeah yeah yeah tease
me and make me tweet it out sometime
Anna says oh true now you're giving me
ideas smile lots of ideas Destiny says
I'll fix it sometime publicly okay until
then you can work on your essays on your
bed while I rub your feet and
legs that is wild that's what I DM you
but I mean well never mind on July 1st
2021 Destiny and Anna appeared on a
panel about mental health and policing
together on July 17th Anna reiterated
her request that they not keep their
friendliness a
secret Destiny says I'm more comfortable
keeping things under wraps but if you're
not comfortable with that then it's your
choice whether you want to continue
chatting with me Anna says but do you
understand why this is shitty for me
Destiny says sure I can understand why
you feel that way but it doesn't change
my position on August 29th 2021 Destiny
complained on stream that Anna was
privately telling people that he is a
dark Triad abuser that's epic when Dan
Dan is Destiny's IRL friend and the he
made like some omega ripoff that's used
by pedophiles and stuff it's awesome on
August 29th 2021 Destiny complained on
stream that Anna was privately telling
people that he's a dark Triad abuser
when Dan expressed dismay that Destiny
was still in contact with Anna Destiny
claimed that the only way to prevent
Anna from going on constant hate uh
tyraids about him is to try and be
somewhat friendly with her keep in mind
he was not being somewhat friendly he
was actively sexting her right Dan said
oh you're just giving into blackmail to
be clear someone's giving you [__] and
you're like okay [__] it I can't fight
it anymore you win we're best friends
where me to be together forever the same
day Destiny dm'd Anna you understand
that it's really bad that you're making
new friends that are already my friend
and venting to them about me the
following day Destiny read aloud the
following statement in a sarcastic
monotone I'm making a public
announcement anybody that doesn't
understand this is getting permanently
banned and we're putting all this behind
us okay listen me and Anna are perfectly
fine she's not a crazy person she is not
a stalker we've had fights publicly
where there has been name calling on
both sides but you know what everything
is cool and we're past all that chat
reacted with comments like blink twice
if she has a gun to your head and she
has something on him on September 22nd
during a 12p person panel hosted by John
zurka Anna tearfully accused Destiny
that's the one I showed you by the way
Anna tearfully accused Destiny of
emotionally abusing her the other
panelists mostly urged her to calm down
and let it go eventually Destiny called
in to defend him himself sounding tired
but panicked he was calling from bed
Destiny accused Anna of con consistently
breaking their agreements to stop
talking about each other he then set
about discrediting her explaining how he
blocked her on Discord and she'd
followed him to other platforms Anna's
rage at the stalker narrative boiled
over shouting she said good night
princess good morning princess really I
Mis representing their relationship
remember all the things you told me
about Molina I've been protecting you
I've been prot protecting you I've been
protecting you from lying to Molina how
dare you if you're going to do this then
I'm leaking it all I'm not protecting
your lying ass
anymore zurka jokingly said Destiny do
you feel protected but then he added no
Anna Anna you're not leaking DMS Destiny
offered another sarcastic exasperated
apology I'm a horrible person I accept
full responsibility I've lied to my
fiance I lied to my son I lied to my
community I'm a horrible manipulative
person and every part of this is my
fault and now I'm moving on I never want
to talk about you publicly again zurka
backed him up by saying yeah that's
great it's closure time Anna Destiny
pledged to stop talking publicly and
privately with Anna and left the call
Anna continued to criticize him 70
minutes later Destiny returned begging
zurka to cut Anna off zurka refused
leading to another hour long argument
about their relationship near the end
Anna asked if you don't want to be
friends with me
why didn't you tell me in private why
didn't you just say that Anna when
somebody blocks you on two different
platforms and doesn't respond to any
messages what do you think that means
again he was texting her he was
exchanging nudes and texting with her at
this time right of course Anna responds
that's the silent treatment though if
you don't want to be friends with me why
didn't you just say that oh my God okay
Destiny said and quickly left the
following day Destiny did a follow-up
stream to explain his thoughts about
Anna I feel a little better though
because now that it blew up on zurka
show I have so many people messaging me
that seem to understand how unhinged she
is I'm not worried about it anymore so
everybody that thought I was being held
hostage you were right my thought
process before and she'll stopped
talking about me publicly the scary
thing is that she started to get into
these communities where I had a whole
bunch of mutual friends so for instance
a whole bunch of people started dming me
and were like hey do you know about this
Ana person got really scared because
then it seems like another Bob s
situation where it's like is she about
to go tell every single person that I'm
an abusive horrible person but now that
everything just came out on zurka show I
think I'm okay with everything now now I
can just ignore her she can spam her
[__] all day I don't care because I
think enough people see her in the arena
blow up where they're like okay she's
got problems what do you think so far
uh I think Destiny is being a really
emotionally manipulative kind of weirdo
here okay I don't know that's that's all
I have to say so far the I'm assuming
the worst hasn't happened yet although
this is bad right but you you did say
there was like assault or something or
rape oh no I I'm Destin he's a rapist
but not for this oh really he's a rapist
because I don't like him oh that's
awesome no to my knowledge he's not
raped any he sexually assaulted people
but he's not raped anybody he's
assaulted people yes he and the person
he assaulted both admit that it was
assault so yeah he's assaulted people
that's crazy yeah yeah all right uh by
the way people might hear clanking that
is me using a nutcracker while I'm
listening to morow tell me about Destiny
drama show yeah was that MC no it wasn't
Merc it was some porn star that he was
hanging out with stream while drunk I
think of course actually I can just go
up here yeah Mia Rose Destiny drunkenly
groped a woman on stream they had a
sexual relationship at the time but both
have acknowledged the incident was an
assault that's gross oh yeah we agree do
you understand how weird that looks if a
small girl streamer complains that
Destiny manipulated her and Destiny is
contacting her other show host telling
them not to let her on you understand
how horrible that looks right a month
later he would do the exact same thing
so the the next day Stardust a destiny
Ally who had brushed off Anna's abuse
claims on the zurka panel did a stream
with Drew our refreshingly sane
psychology student who' advocated for
Anna a year prior Drew told Stardust
that he was concerned that the increased
attention on Anna would be more would
bring more harassment her way after the
zurka hosted screaming match it was
inevitable that the drama vultures would
come up uh for their pieces of uh of the
Anna Pie and they'd be encouraged to
help themselves as long as they were
promulgating Destiny's narrative within
22 minutes Dan joined the call I thought
okay hold on let's change the song a
little bit might skip a little more get
to the good ooh this Chestnut is black
I'm going what that's disgusting dude I
think that one was rotted you're [__]
dude yeah dude one time I bit into this
pean or no was it a pean or it something
down and it's like covered in mold no it
was a hazelnut it was a hazelnut it was
covered in mold tasted
horrible thank you resie for the raid
thank you who's res resir res who resir
resir
yeah yeah he's epic dude is he epic yeah
he just raided me epic that is epic
that's pretty epic yeah he did let me
see if there might be a good documentary
on this CU I think we could uh you know
how's this Destiny is a massive streamer
with massive amounts of influence in on
the global movie that is the internet
he's been through much hardship in his
life but will he be able to escape the
wrath of anore watch and find out in
this psychological horror mother I slept
with
danger oh is he on the side of Destiny
that's not what I want that's not what I
want to see that's not what you want to
see confirms my opinions yeah I want
something that confirms my opinions to
be honest with
you yeah exactly that's more drama it's
more interesting yeah everybody in the
comments is just saying how she's an
insane [__] whatever whatever not
interested what is this dementia Dan
what is the counter argument what do you
think the counter what do you
mean what do you think Destiny Blazers
would defend with I think they would
generally say that Anna is an adult and
she can consent but I think that
undermines what actually happened okay I
think you know I could be wrong I
suppose
could be I could be probably not do you
run no I'm incredibly
overweight all right let's do some more
reading I suppose sure you know listen
Dan Daniel winus
listen I instead of reading that whole
thing cuz that's a it's this thing is
insanely long okay I want to AOG
somebody let's read the summary and then
you can either leave or we can stay and
AOG someone all right what is AOG
we're just going to stalk someone on the
internet we're going to maybe stalk an
wise teach me all right teach me the
ways read read this summary this is a
list of what what Mr girl deems to be
the most important cases of Destiny's uh
fortitude all right one second I have a
mouth full of nuts yeah yeah yeah uh of
yours D kid a teenager disrupted
Destiny's ability to stream and Destiny
later said he planned to kill the boy
and his father but decided not to
because it wasn't worth the rest Mia
Rose Destiny drunkenly groped to woman
on stream they had a sexual relationship
at the time but both have acknowledged
the incident as an assault blue te after
Destiny leaked a woman's nudes to his
friend she tweeted out photos of his
genitals from his Twitter account
Destiny considered trying to get her
dropped from her scholarship Molina
Destiny's wife they met when she was a
20-year-old fan and she was 30 they have
both characterized Destiny's treatment
of her as psychologically abusive and
Molina has said it makes her feel
suicidal Bob seven Molina's confidon and
sexting partner for a year when Bob told
Molina and a mutual friend of Destiny he
thought Destiny was manipulative Destiny
made false harassment allegations
against him thank for the raid welcome
Raiders sorry go ahead thank you Raiders
hello Raiders Raiders of the Lost Arc
that is yeah that's what we call them
yeah exactly the Lost Arc is the stream
actually when the women didn't support
the smearer campaign Destiny smeared
them as well Anna Destiny had sex with a
small streamer who became attached to
him when she criticized his lifestyle he
called her an insane Stocker which only
provoked her to criticize him further at
the same time that Destiny convinced his
fans and orbiters and Anna's abuse
claims should be ignored for her own
good he was sexing her at one point
Destiny threatened to leak Anna's nud if
she leaked his sex he also directed his
fans to participate in harassing and
doxing Anna and retaliation for her Abus
claims Sam Destiny supported a mayoral
candidate in Omaha who fired him when
Destiny's reputation attracted negative
press coverage Sam was a local college
aged resident who criticized
him through a battle of harsh and vulgar
words Destiny emailed Sam's employer and
tried to get him fired ooh that's rough
Darius we're all big Darius wait are we
Darius fans around here I'm a Darius fan
you're a Darius fan of course I'm a
Darius fan I love uh like the the black
autistic kid Darius I love that Darius
Darius is he black no no no you we're
not talking about the same Darius I
don't know this Destiny Orbiter whatever
his name is okay continue Contin a
different darus okay sure so where's
darus oh yeah Molina a former sex
partner of Darius asked him to move to
Austin with her after Destiny cheated on
her they had a falling out and Darius
was suicidal Destiny presided over a
live stream fight between the two and
viously mocked areas Merck a former sex
partner of Destinies publicly mock her
suicide attempt three weeks before it
happened after it happened yeah before
would be an interesting premonition
denims and little fox little fox oh
denims is you know denim you know denims
yeah I know Den um okay two young female
streamers both in sexual relationships
with Des wait what no way denims was in
a relationship with Destiny yeah read go
go on read it okay yeah both in sexual
relationships with Destiny after Destiny
and Molina withdrew an
invitation to host the two in their
apartment Destiny smeared denims as a
liar on stream because he was afraid one
of them might make a false sexual
misconduct allegation against him that
is insane I had no idea that denim's
that's like the Lauren southern thing
too that's so crazy dude he's on he's on
all he's on thin ice all right we're
about to we're about to kick Destiny out
of the house okay he's he's on they're
on thin ice pal but no thin ice is Nick
fles then he's on thin ice yeah um white
n Mo a small trans streamer whom Destiny
flirted with while boosting her career
likely not knowing she was trans around
the time she started appearing on camera
Destiny lost interest and stopped
growing her stream Bosch first a fan
then an Orbiter then a competitor
Destiny bounced on the opportunity to
humiliate and sabotage Vos when he was
accused of sexual harassment Destiny
later cut ties with Vos because of
because his partner and friend
campaigned for Destiny's D platform
after Destiny made a call for violence
against BLM riers all right I'm not
going to lie the vosch one Destiny's
like kind of Justified on um from what
I've seen maybe maybe I'm he Vos was a
really big sex past and dmed a bunch of
women and like was really gross to them
and Desy kept him around and then like
the only yeah so I think that's you know
kept him around is weird I think the
worst part is that he kept them around
and like didn't have a problem with it
probably because he was used to doing
similar things anyway okay lav assorted
stories
lavy old I've heard the name lab isn't
she is she the crazy one I I don't
remember potentially racist you know
continue go ahead go ahead goe I have a
24 year-old who became sexually involved
with Destiny as she encourage her to
start streaming and helped her grow her
stream Destiny set her up to be
routinely humiliated and harassed by his
community the point of feeling suicidal
she spoke out about it he and her he and
his orbiters launched a misogynistic
harassment campaign against her I'm not
going to lie I don't know if I buy this
one I the lav one is is relatively light
compared to everything else but I do I
think he's I I believe yeah I agree with
what he wrote for the most part for the
most part okay kind of overblown to make
him look worse in my opinion I think you
could definitely frame the laugh to look
worse than it is or worse than what he
wrote I think you could definitely make
it look way worse I think I think it's
fine I mean really what he did he just
like [__] he would like just make
like he would say insane [__] on live
streams and then he wouldn't like say
hey don't go talk like he he would just
allow his fan base to be like [__]
crazy to her you know oh I see and he
wouldn't prevent it he wouldn't stop it
I don't think he ever said like I could
be wrong but I don't think he ever said
like go harass this person right it was
just a lot of like you know it's it's
obvious what he's doing he's trying to
Target harassment towards them without
like overtly saying go harass them in my
opinion really you think so I think so
oh this I think this this Walnut might
be moldy hold on I can't tell you're
eating moldy walnuts yeah yeah I am yeah
you know what do you have a problem with
that no all right queman Quan did right
in queman viewers was the uh was him on
jstock with Anna and lav was that good
cuz I'm very interested in Anna I want
to watch Anna content so is that good to
watch for for Anna stuff yes a we got
two yeses and an eh all right should I
move on with the list or should I wait
for whatever uh you can read me in
Destiny this is the Nick Fontes one this
is going to be too yeah me and Destiny's
platforming of Nick Fuentes I became
Destiny's friend and orbitor and slowly
realized he was intentionally creating
situations where I would be hurt or
humiliated when Destiny became friendly
with far white extremist Nick quentes I
confronted him Destiny banned me from
his supper quentes his followers got me
banned from YouTube and I cut ties with
Destiny I'm not going to lie I do not
care about this one at all the Fontes
argument with Destiny is kind of stupid
there's there's way more that goes into
it that he's not touching upon um okay
but that is like a a a summ like a
decent summarization he was upset that
Nick he was talking to Nick Fontes uh in
his mind it was harmful uh you know all
that [__] so we can continue to go
through all of this and read the
summarization of um of all of these
right